[Music]
so the idea here is that he goes that
you're you don't want to
play your escapes from side control
okay so you're thinking ahead he opened
the guard he's coming around there's
that five step you see and you've moved
inside his Circle so not after the fact
not here and then you're try to
do he's making a circle you move inside
his
Circle and you're up you see then move
out of the
way and you
have coming around right move inside the
circles it's the same thing here
so he got through cool and your movement
and you have so I'm coming
around here and the same thing I now
don't want to push into that that's
what's giv them so again I ride this
over okay and then you're now chest to
chest and then you can
reacquire side control so I don't fight
it so I'm not trying to smash it I'm
staying at the edge kind of like EO okay
okay so you coming around you feel it
move out of your way coming
around inside that Circle so he's
starting to pass I'm looking for the
bicep control I feel him go there I go
around this way onto the tricep
okay
again it's going that way go to the
tricep okay sit up this way
let's move this way
okay again a lot of it depends on what
he's doing
so uh don't make techniques out of it so
as I come here and I'm coming up you see
and you're like w there's too much space
here you see so I get
out it's coming around and try countered
you go to here you see oh there's just
too much weight so I kind of sit up you
see I kind of sit up and I start moving
myself
out do one more and and we won't take it
into a reversal so I'm going this way
this way now keep going okay he's trying
to get on so you're going to
roll this way he keeps going and you
keep that okay and then when you come in
and you can get BL fly so the principle
those is the same on the
circle it's not down here and trying
it
reverse it's as he's moving you're going
this way
okay and you start
working this door he's
going and I go this
way okay if he's going to give me chest
to chest then I'll then I'm going to
stay down but if he's if there's space
or whatever then I'm I'm going to try to
escape and get more Mobility going okay
so um
let's say he's down and on on this one
okay I'm coming around and he starts to
turn that way inside the circle okay now
if he gets enough and I'm here like that
he's going to get chest to chest you see
oh there we go okay you do the same
thing right but if I'm coming around and
he's here and I'm here like that he's
not going to he's not going to get it a
second before before I clear this okay
so he sits up and he goes out and then
he's working butterfly guard you see so
I come to clothes on him and he's
already got the
sweep and then he takes it does that
make sense